on Friday right around five o'clock I
noticed my phone powered down I went to
plug it in and when I did they came up
to the startup screen that you get the
first time you you know we're getting
ready to register a new phone I tried to
you know start the data recovery process
where you can reinstall from a backup I
use iCloud backups and when I enter my
iCloud password it was wrong and at that
point I still didn't realize something
was wrong I just thought that there was
some sort of software glitch or
something or I was you know fat
fingering my password or something like
that and then I went to plug it into my
macbook cuz I also back it up to my
macbook and I have another backup there
and when I opened my computer the first
thing that happened was a alert popped
up from notifying that my Google account
password was wrong about it you know
whereas trying to wear iCal was trying
to look at my Google Calendar and then
the screen went gray and there was a
this gray screen with fordable text
fields asking me to interrupt pin and at
that point I knew right away that
something was really really wrong
and I had I just got home from work and
so I work back was right there too and I
just grabbed my iPad out of there and
looked at it and the iPad screen was
also on this startup screen and I
immediately thought I was being hacked
and and I I didn't realize there's an
iCloud hack and so that site so the
first thing I did was turn off my
internet connection I hadn't really
thought through all the consequences
immediately and the first thing I
thought is sort of how bad is this and
are they in my you know other accounts
are they in my online banking are they
in you know all these other services
that I've got and I I checked gene I
went to my neighbor's house and I didn't
want to use any computers in my home or
any of my you know other services if it
was coming in through my internet
connection Mike my first thought was you
know that somebody had somehow gotten
online my local net
and with my neighbor's house borrowed
their computer realized right away that
my Google account had been had been
deleted and they were posting to my
Twitter and and I was just just the
possibilities in my mind were just
totally reeling i immediate start think
about my online banking and things of
that nature and wondering if someone's
in those I couldn't check those because
I used one password and since I used one
password I don't actually know any my
passwords they're all these really
complicated long alpha numerics and
because all my devices were wiped I
couldn't I couldn't go in and look at
what was stored in one password and so I
was just absolutely panicking and then
the thing that I really started thinking
about I was on the phone with Apple tech
support which is an hour and a half long
phone call was am I gonna be able to get
the data back that was on my Mac because
that was there there were there were all
kinds of documents and things that I had
there nowhere else and more to the point
I mean the thing that I keep coming back
to is there all these pictures of my
daughter and my family and and just you
know pictures of my wife and things that
I don't have anywhere else and I was I
was pretty devastated
thinking that I may have lost those and
I still in devastated thing that I may
have lost him I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to get it back yet or not I was
I was actually pretty jacked up on
adrenaline through about right now
actually today was the first thing I
feel like I was kinda started to come
down from from all the panic and
adrenaline has started really kind of
contemplating what's happened and and as
I've been doing that I've been really
I've been really sad you know and so
that's been kind of a you know that's
that's been something that I wouldn't
have really thought about so much I
guess macaws it makes you just sort of
feel like especially because I wasn't
backing up it makes me feel like a lot
of the stuff that I could have prevented
stuff that was my fault I mean I'm a I'm
a technology journalist under technology
journalist since the 90s you know I mean
I I should I know better than to not be
backing up I know better
I mean I was backing up my my iPhone I
was backing up my iPad and I have a
desktop computer that I was backing up
but I wasn't backing up my laptop you
know and I think one of the reasons for
that is sort of the way I think about it
I think of my desktop as being the place
where I store all my things but I don't
actually you know end up transferring
all these photos and things that I work
on on my laptop over that desktop very
often and and the last time I had done
it was more than a year ago and so you
know that stuff's just gone or maybe
maybe it's gone I don't know
we'll find out yeah there were a lot of
crazy comments people blaming me blaming
Apple blaming each other blaming you
know I mean there and there was a lot of
you know there was a lot of kind of
schadenfreude a you know type stuff
where people were laughing about this
happening to me and calling each other
names and threatening each other all I
just it was it was madness and you know
I don't know I mean I just given
everything that was going on that never
really bothered me because the other
problems were so bad that the methought
I'm it didn't bother me still don't
really bother me I'll walk down the
comments but I wouldn't really bothered
by them I don't know why people you know
I mean I suppose it's sort of I'm not
the first one to make this analogy
that's was sort like being a driver in a
car and you know it's really easy to
flip somebody off when you're in a
vehicle and you know that they can't get
to you and so I think that there is a
little bit of that going on of comments
and you know people just I don't I mean
I can't explain people on Friday night
yeah on Friday night I got in touch with
the guy via Twitter when we started at
messaging each other and then we we
followed each other I think he actually
had messaged me first initially and it
was it pretty quickly became apparent
that he knew a lot of details about the
attack that someone you know would have
you would have had to have been taking
part to know those things
and so then we just we basically started
talking and I and I I wanted to find out
you know really how it was done and he
was willing to tell me you know it was
weird it was really weird because of
course I was you know a little bit a
little bit of course I was mad but I
also wanted to try and be really
rational about it I wanted to try and
understand exactly how this had happened
and what the extent of the damage was
and I felt like a better way to approach
that than saying oh you son of a
you just ruined my life was too you know
was to try and engage and do it in a
dispassionate manner and that turned out
to be pretty effective it didn't help me
very much in terms of getting things
back in order because they went to such
extremes nuking all my accounts and and
and you know deleting everything that
there was not really much order to be
restored that they could do you know in
like you know they wiped my MacBook I
mean like even though 'men though the
light didn't finish it went far enough
along that even when Apple reset the pen
and it you know it it won't boot it's
it's you know it's in a non usable State
so when I talked to the stuff I found
out from them was not very useful for
getting stuff back even though he gave
me all these temporary account passwords
and things like that it was very useful
for understand what happened especially
cuz it took a couple of days to sort of
extract the level of detail I needed
from him for that at first he didn't
seem to want to contact me via email or
other channels but his time went on over
the weekend he he basically set up a
disposable email address and and we were
able to you know I was able to
understand like in more detail how he
had done this and and we were able to to
reproduce those things ourselves and you
know so so that that wound up being very
helpful he the reasons he gave for doing
it were pretty pretty I mean I
just reasons I don't really understand I
mean he said that they saw my Twitter
handle it was a three-character Twitter
handle it's my first name and they just
wanted it and so they took it and they
they they I I'm not sure about this but
I my impressionist they were looking at
various Twitter handles they saw mine
and they saw that it had a domain
attached to it and so when they saw that
they clicked through to my domain name
where they saw my gmail address on my
demand they did a who is at that point
they started they were well on their way
to having the data they would need to do
an attack and they you know they were
then they looked at my gmail account
recovery and I didn't have two-step
authentication set up and I had a they
saw that I had a doc me email address as
my recovery email and that he knew this
technique to get and to get through
Apple's tech support and so when he saw
that they decided to go for it and take
my and take my Twitter and that was that
was the longest shorter but I mean there
wasn't it wasn't malicious it wasn't
personal it wasn't you know I mean as he
said you know he didn't have any heat
against me it was just they just they
just they just did it I've been super
paranoid and stressed out you know on
Sunday for example I sent an email to to
Apple corporate basically asking them of
the long list of questions and then a
few minutes later my I got an alert that
popped up on my iPhone that said my I
count my iCloud password was wrong and I
completely panicked and I thought though
it's happening again
and I immediately put my phone in
airplane mode and you know went to went
to log on to iCloud on a my wife's
computer and couldn't couldn't log on
and was freaking out and about this time
the thigh I use Google Voice and I start
getting a call
into the Google Voice account Riga the
Google horse message actually it's from
Apple tech support and my case had been
escalated
I guess shortly after I sent this this
email to Apple corporate and they'd they
they had changed my password but I was I
was convinced that it was all happening
again you know and I've I've just been
you know I've been really edgy ever
since then like I've been like I've been
wary of the emails and replying to I've
been I'm I'm paranoid
I mean I've actually been dealing with
this so intensely that I'm I'm I mean
there's so many things to do that
there's so many things to do there's so
many things to do and like every day I
keep remembering other things that that
I need to fix other services that I need
to change a password on other you know
just other accounts that that you know
maybe aren't secure I mean aren't you
know aren't vital butter but you know
maybe your link to some other thing and
I just you know there's just so much to
do that you know i've been i've actually
been intimately tied to my devices since
this happened although i I don't have my
laptop which is sort of my core device
and it's it's it's really weird not
having that you know I I hope it's gonna
result in some policy changes I because
I have seen quite a few other people
describe a you know something happened
them in a very similar manner where
they're I haven't seen anyone else who's
gotten a MacBook white I don't believe
but I have seen people who've had their
devices their their iPhones and iPads
remotely wiped and that have seemed to
trace back to Apple tech support the
hackers claim they got the last four
digits of one of my credit cards via
Amazon and Amazon today changed one of
their systems so that you basically
can't do that anymore
and so I'm hoping you know Apple does
something similar Apple corporate won't
confirm with me repeatedly and despite
you know my you know continued demands
for an explanation exactly how they said
their policies weren't followed
completely well the word completely
leaves a lot of room for anything you
know but it's my understanding from
talking to Apple Care Apple Care told me
this on Friday a very high level Apple
care person told me this on Saturday and
an Apple care person who apparently is
the only person who has the ability to
make any changes to my account right now
would not deny this on Sunday that if
you give them your Apple ID the last
four digits of a credit card and a
billing address that's all that a tech
support person needs to issue a
temporary password and the last four
digits of a credit card are so easy to
get because they're considered insecure
by so many you know but by credit card
company so I mean even you know if you
look at the receipt that you get when
you you know after you pay for your meal
or get out of a taxi or you know or
anything like that it will show you the
last four digits and not not the others
and while I can understand that they are
Apple may have this is my speculation
that they may have been trying to be in
compliance with requirements that don't
allow for full exposure of credit cards
using those last four digits as a you
know as a means to verify identity with
especially long with things as easy to
get as an address and a email address
just it just it just really it shocks me
one of the last conversations I had with
them before I published Monday I asked
him you know do you feel any remorse for
this do you you know you understand that
like this is this is my life my you know
my little girl who's you know pictures
you know you are maybe gone forever and
I've lost all those and you know do you
understand that why I'm you know why I'd
be upset about that and you feel me
remorse when he said he did you know I
mean he says he claims that he's trying
to expose Apple security loopholes and
you know I don't have any idea I mean I
can't speak to what is his real motives
are or aren't and and but he did say
that he was remorseful and he related it
back to his own life and said he
couldn't imagine how devastating that be
for his parents their lose all the
pictures of him
or and you know I mean I don't know I
don't know I love the Internet III you
know I it's it's it's been a way that
I've used to communicate with people and
make creator more profound connections
in my life since you know I was very
young man and uh I was in college and I
have no intention of not being online
anymore I mean I where using Internet
connected devices I do this has been a
wake-up call for me that I need to take
security a lot more seriously I've you
know I've started doing things like
using two-factor authentication on
Google and I've disconnected my devices
from the find my services on iCloud I've
just I've made changes that that I think
will make me more secure but I fully
intend to embrace the Internet and the
web and all in all of its various
splendor if you're a gmail user I'd make
sure you turn on two-factor
authentication
you always hear this but I would back up
your machine as often as possible if
it's got any kind of information on it
that you don't want to be lost and you
know for now at least until Apple has
changed something
I wouldn't use find my Mac because if it
does give someone the ability to
remotely wipe your machine without you
being able to stop it you know that's
that's just going to continue to be a
problem